pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieuse et les épis curieux je ne
sais pas où vous en êtes dans votre
journée si c'est le lever ou le coucher
mais si vous êtes au petit déjeuner vous
est peut-être en train de déguster un
délicieux croissant trempés dans le
chocolat ou un café au lait j'adore
[Musique]
c'est une jolie pâtisserie n'ayons pas
peur des mots symbolise un peu l'art de
vivre à la française
la recette de ce croissant au beurre
avec de la pâte feuilletée à d'ailleurs
sans doute vu le jour en france dans les
années 1920 mais bon comme je n'ai
aucune envie de vous rouler dans la
farine
je dois vous avouer qu'à l'origine le
croissant au plus tôt et les pâtisseries
en forme de croissant n'ont pas vu le
jour dans l'hexagone pour ceux qui
aiment les belles histoires autant que
les croissants sachez que la légende
situe ses origines en 1683 à vienne en
autriche alors que les ottomans
assiègent la ville nuit
il décide d'entrer dans la ville par un
souterrain mais des boulangers viennois
déjà l'oeuvre les repères donne
l'alertent et l'aso est repoussée pour
commémorer l'événement les boulangers
viennois invente une pâtisserie en forme
de croissant
reprenons le symbole représenté sur le
drapeau hautement ça évidemment c'est la
légende
alors certes le croissant est autrichien
le premier a semble-t-il était
commercialisé aux alentours de 1840 le
type pearl
mais à l'époque ils étaient
confectionnés à partir d'une pâte
briochée son origine est sûrement moins
épique et encore plus lointaine il ya
plus de 2000 ans déjà les perses les
assyriens les grecs et les premiers
chrétiens cervelle et pâtisseries en
forme de croissant lors des cérémonies
religieuses
quoi qu'il en soit que je ne vais pas me
faire prier pour en croquer un et le
déguster
religieusement bon
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands
en voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]